that is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk and i am dave
jewett the host of loadout the gamespot
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's episode
we're going to be chatting through some
of the many and varied shotguns that
crop up in our favorite games
this thing is basically wind up so crank
on the front literally
comedy wind-up mechanism i think if
you're using this in a combat situation
i think you have larger problems
if you like this kind of content please
make sure to subscribe as we have
episodes of loadout going up every
sunday and you can already check out our
previous episode all about the history
and gaming legacy of the shotgun on top
of that we'll still be showing jonathan
new gaming arsenal's every saturday so
make sure to check out those as well
right let's get into the chat
so shotguns
are a massive family of firearms
obviously very diverse
and we've seen examples of all of these
in video games and movies but can you
take us through
what each sort of type of shotgun is
yeah this isn't everything needless to
say it's what would fit on the table but
so starting from what's furthest away
from me there standard side by side
double barrel shotgun
that would be recognizable to someone
from the 18th century they might wonder
where the mechanism had gone it's
actually now hidden inside
but same basic configuration nice wooden
stock
by this point we've got a lever on the
top there feel free to pick that up
and have a look
and it also breaking the barrels doesn't
just open it up to to load
it also [ __ ] the thing and if it has
ejectors it also [ __ ] the ejectors so
is it a case of
pushing that to the side
yeah and then a bit of leverage which by
the way is when when people saw these
off to do nefarious things it becomes
harder to load them it's not as easy as
games make it out to be is it
[Music]
i'm treating everything with a sort of
kid gloves i know yeah the collection is
very important so you know things aren't
going to behave in quite the same way
because we're trying to be careful
and then we've got the remington 870 the
the um archetypal pump action shotgun
1950s vintage pretty much
but it's still around today still in
production all sorts of different
configurations and of course has been
modernized as all other firearms that
are still around have been
plastic furniture rails i mean this this
is very it's very vanilla it's got a
very an old-fashioned bead front sight
and if you want to
have a look at that and then a sort of a
rib across the top of the action
so it's instinctive aiming still with
this yeah and this like so this this one
in particular has had quite a life
and is replicated in video games as it's
very much modernized
even 2042 has a version of this just
futurised as much as possible so it's
it's
i suppose would you consider it long in
the tooth when it comes to pop culture
yeah i mean not in terms of the design
in its niche of a pump action shotgun
it's still as good as you'll get
but in terms of pump action shotguns
being relevant to what happens in real
life not so much this would be still a
self-defense home defense sporting
hunting maybe even practical manually
operated sporting shotgun
and perhaps you might still use a
version for blowing off door hinges i
can't see it in 2042 but
but you know it has the advantage of
manual operation so you don't have to
rely on a mechanism and therefore
enough oomph to use technical term from
the cartridge to actually cycle it
because you're doing all the cycling
with your
with your own muscles so it always will
always have that advantage
[Applause]
and that's something you've brought up
when we've talked about the spaz 12 um
when we've been doing expert reacts the
fact that this is both pump action and
semi-automatic the pump action was for
using those low power loads
but that's one of the another one of the
things that games sort of
dance around whereas usually if it's
just buckshot chances are you'd be using
it
semi-automatic
but
games quite often
go one of two ways and it's like no this
is a pump action shotgun or this is a
semi-automatic shotgun yeah but this one
also has its i suppose it's own pop
culture lineage and we've talked about
it before
but being like heavily influencing the
pulse rifle in aliens this this this one
to me
speaks more sci-fi because of aliens
terminated to totally things like that
and it just it just looks more sci-fi i
mean nothing i guess there's a spin-off
of that hybrid mechanism pump not that
many shotguns do pump or semi
um that gives that gives you this very
blocky heavily vented forend that just
makes it look way more sci-fi
oh goodness
and then one with
a big internal is there a big internal
revolving drum yeah
of the striker that is i remember when i
saw that in the video game for the first
time i was like i don't know if that's a
real thing and then you go and look it
up and you're like oh it is in fact
but that's also a very interesting one
but we don't see this mechanism in
shotguns
too much at all do we and it's very much
a again it's something we've talked
about in expert reacts reloading this
thing on like battlefield 4 and they're
doing it way faster than i think is
really
accepted as a human being could do
because really it's not
if this runs empty
and during a combat situation i can't
imagine trying to thumb all those in is
going to be an enjoyable experience
i think if you're using this in a combat
situation i think you have larger
problems
this it's you know nice try but um it's
funny how we're getting maybe
less
less reliable and less practical as we
go across the table
so interesting idea to try and marry the
single action well not really single
action so i can actually sort of
demonstrate a bit of how this works so
this is the protector striker this thing
is basically wind up so
crank on the front literally
comedy wind-up mechanism doesn't play a
song annoyingly no i won't wind it all
the way and then a loading gate on the
back very much like a single action
revolver flip that up just a little bit
of sheet metal shove in your cartridge
one at a time
and then you would actually have to
use the trigger to
dunk it to the next slot
and then if you if you had empty
uh fight cases in there by the way
you're also having to use a single
action revolver style ejector rod
and you'd have to turn that each time as
well yeah then your fresh one goes in
then you clunk it round again
knock out the case shove in the fresh
one until you have
clunked it all the way around
then you can close that up and you're
ready to shoot making sure that you have
enough
turns on the on the clock spring
to actually work reliably for all of
those shots so interesting idea arm sill
but
maybe not that practical
again it's one of those
weapons that i think it's it's life in
video games
so ridiculously outweighs its life
in the real world like it's not a hugely
common shotgun in video games but
even so even so yeah i i think the the
us 12 is sort of similar um
but i think this one has its niche of
like we've talked about the shotgun
nation you know big powerful
and
this one has like the big chunky lines
to it it's very
sort of intense looking and i think
because of that a lot of games sort of
lean towards towards it as well but this
is an example of a magazine fed one
right yeah so i think of this as a
cartoon m16
so it does come with the option for a
box magazine as well
but of course we typically encounter it
well not always actually but usually
with the drum
which inherently makes it less reliable
you're better off with any box magazine
fed shotgun and they are becoming maybe
more of a thing now for sort of
practical
shooting competitions
although most competitors competitors
are still using tube magazines they just
they lend themselves better to the
shotgun format
apparently apart from anything else you
can only fit so many rounds in a massive
long extendo mag yeah
so but this this does have the drum
um and then it has the sort of ar-15
ergonomics this this entire lower
section is designed to to ape
the selector safety the trigger trigger
mechanism the pistol grip it's even got
like a giant m16 type dust cover
huge carry handle reminiscent of the old
m16a1
even it's got the same rear sight
arrangement albeit with slightly
different
sight
so yeah oh and it it ejects
can be set up to eject out of the left
side which is an early example of ambi
dexterity also the cocking handle can be
swapped to the other side this is south
korean by the way the usas 12 or you sas
12.
i think anyone who's played battlefield
will still have bad memories of people
shooting frag rounds oh yeah i have this
thing yeah i do actually
yeah it's all coming back
it's a dark place
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
it please do like the video and
subscribe and maybe even let me know in
the comment section down below or on
twitter at a regular dave what you'd
like to see an episode on if you want
more video game firearms content you can
watch the previous series of this show
or check out our weekly series of expert
reacts where i show our friends at the
royal armouries a slew of guns to break
down
next week on loadout using a silver soul
would be about as much good as trying to
fight someone with a stick of licorice
until next time i've been your host dave
dewitt thanks again for watching and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you